oh you think a good guy would go and
stop a bad guy with a gun well not only
do I believe it you believe it because
even when you make these arguments well
you think a good guy with a gun is gonna
stop him yeah I do
that's just ridiculous you should leave
it to the cops all right so I want to
talk about that it's it's been all over
the Internet
here's my question of the day before we
start what do you think about the
concept of arming teachers or at least
allowing teachers to carry on campus
it's been a hot button issue ever since
President Trump suggested the
possibility of it well let's let's roll
a clip first it would be teachers and
coaches and this would only be obviously
for people that are very adept at
handling a gun and it would be it's
called concealed carry that what a
teacher would have a concealed gun on
them they'd go for special training it
would be on there and they would be
there and you would no longer have a
gun-free zone okay so here's the thing
obviously I don't there's a difference
been man dating between forcing teachers
to carry guns and allowing them to now
so this very concept and I haven't
understood it at all so again that's
maybe have a blind spot tweet me comment
below cuz everyone in the media has been
eager to dismiss this as a crazy
completely unworkable idea as though
we're all on board which I'm not let's
let's roll the clips we expect so much
out of our teachers we expect them to be
teachers social workers psychologists
this is nursery dr. Mary Ann I don't
think that we should expect them to
officers and we also have so much
research that shows kind of more guns in
any setting lead to more gun violence in
any city whether that's routes Idaho
where you hear the President and the
United States say the answer is to give
every teacher in America a gun which
that is insane that is an insane idea I
was a teacher
mm-hmm-hmm believe you don't want me to
have a gun
I'm well I've no argument here now by
the way happy notification bail if
you're watching on YouTube because
subscribing isn't enough just hit it up
there in the top left top right here's
the thing I don't want to force any
teachers to carry guns I don't wanna
make it a policy where teachers are
carrying your you sign up to become a
teacher you have to carry a gun that's a
terrible idea
okay so if we're going to talk about
this sensibly
let's find common ground how about
allowing teachers and faculty who are
already Cpl CCW LTC depending on your
state they're holders to carry on campus
just like anywhere else how about that
let's just allow them to carry on campus
as they do at the mall as they do at the
supermarket people who are already
carrying so we talked about the day the
data suggests that anywhere there's a
gun there's going to be more violence
okay not exactly how about all the car
how about the parking on all the cars
are those teachers who leave their
firearm in the car this is exactly
parking on a war zone yeah don't got
it's like Detroit so let's look at the
stat 98% of mass shootings occur in
gun-free zones okay
that's a fact another fact that
concealed carry holders are the most
law-abiding demographic you can find in
the United States as far as according to
my research maybe there's another one
let me know
so CCW permit holders are actually
convicted of felonies and misdemeanors
at less than a sixth the rate of police
officer gosh so even though police are
convicted of crimes significantly less
than the average citizen a concealed
carry holder is more law-abiding than an
off-duty police officer by the way
that's you in the statistics that the
black lives matter activists would say
but those those statistics are corrupt
those cops never get caught in crimes
we're even using those and they're less
likely I can't go through the stats
we've talked about this to CDC right
Obama ordered the CDC to research gun
violence didn't like what they found
500,000 to 3 million cases a year of a
defensive firearm being used potentially
saving lives now even if you just take a
tenth of that number ok take a tenth of
it and say that's how many lives guns
safer your it is exponentially higher
yeah the number of lives taken from
firearm certainly if you exclude
suicides we are not talking about any
new kind of policy okay we are talking
simply about allowing people who have
already gone through the process to
carry their firearm in a
to be responsible and have proven to be
more law-abiding citizens than any of
them agreement that we know we're simply
affording them that same right when
they're in a position where they could
protect their students or their school
that's all we're saying just allow the
same rule of law to apply on campus as
anywhere else yeah yeah I was gonna say
we were talking about this before if if
a teacher has a firearm and there's
somebody out in the hallways shooting
and they go out and fire one round that
person is no longer shooting innocent
people anymore he's determined to figure
out who was shooting at him and now he's
trying to survive yeah at least people
have time to get away well that's
something else like really important
your this fantasy of these survivalist
that you're gonna go out and stop them
with your handgun absolutely now here's
why even if someone goes in with a rifle
and I'm the first to admit that a rifle
is obviously would be my weapon of
choice and defensive scenario over a
pistol you know idiot to not admit that
however someone going into a school okay
their goal is to mow down as many people
as humanly possible because they're evil
bastards as evil bastards do they're not
up against the wall with defensive
scenarios okay all right who's coming my
way because you do that everyone's going
outside of the room you have no one else
to shoot so in a scenario of a school
shooting this person has to be exposed
because they have to move through the
hallways to try and take as many lives
as possible where of course a teacher or
a faculty member who knows the layout of
the school could get a jump on them now
am I saying again
you're gonna have Rambo come out and
stop the next school shooting no but it
certainly would give them me it
certainly would it would increase the
odds by the way I'm just talking about
increasing the odds - better than 98% of
mass shootings occurring your way
gun-free zones
yeah that's thing for me like I like the
odds I like the odds they're stacked
there they only improve when you put a
gun in there and in I trust my fifth my
son or daughter's fifth grade math
teachers their chance of hitting
something more than I trust the
terrorists chances of missing well we
talk about good guys with a gun staffing
with a bad guy with a gun it's one of
those things that it is so truthful that
it is ironically disarming factually so
the left just tries to say here comes a
good guy with a gun myth again but it's
not so it's just some examples to put a
face to in Chicago a man opened fire in
Logan Square
uber driver with a gun shot him six
times anding the attack burning was
injured there was a Plymouth
Pennsylvania we covered that gunman
opened fired a bar killing one person
one person concealed carry shot him
several times dropping him Tennessee
gunman
fire in church she was stopped by a
church uh sure who held him at gunpoint
until law enforcement arrived of course
you're Stephen Wilford who we've had on
this show he used an ar-15 to stop the
Sutherland Springs shooter from
continuing as massacre after killing 27
people by the way not to me appeals at
all that's that's few and far between
and far between if you look at the
statistics but let's go with that
there's still no other way around the
fact that even if it's not a good guy
with a gun civilian all of the other
active shooters who were stopped by
police with guns there's no way around
the good guy with gun stopping bad guy
with guns okay look it's either a good
guy with a gun who's a civilian or a cop
it sort of comes down to you or you know
I will give you this if you are lucky by
some stroke of God maybe they kill
themselves the active shooter you get
that and that's why we've we list deaths
we don't list the active shooters and we
write to outside of that either
leadership but they're still being
stuffed with a gun
so yeah this idea that oh you think a
good guy would go and stop a bad guy
with a gun well not only do I believe it
you believe it because even when you
make these arguments well you think a
good guy with a gun is gonna stop him
yeah I do that's just ridiculous you
should leave it to the cops hey did you
like this video of course you did let's
there's something wrong with you in
which case you can comment below what's
your problem with this video we want to
hear from you and we promise you 100% I
give you my word as my bond will answer
every single negative comment for those
who are normal you can leave a thumbs up
and subscribe